vous avez reçu la première dose lowe's
d'astrazeneca mais suite à la polémique
et au buzz médiatique vous refuser de
recevoir la deuxième dose mais d'abord
je voudrais revenir à l'origine pourquoi
c'est le vaccin astrazeneca qui vous a
été administré avec sa de disponible
c'est ce qu'on disait nous nous sommes
dans une clinique de chroniques
donc on est comme prioritaire avec des
personnes âgées
la semaine dernière nous avions 1
seulement voilà ça aussi doses pour
toutes à clinique nous est prioritaire
parce que vous avez des facteurs de
comorbidité du moment je suis
insuffisance rénale terminale jadis tous
les jours à domicile
donc c'est très compliqué pour nous j'ai
été obligé de vacciner avec cette
molécule ce que j'ai subi deux
interventions très récemment
émond et frelinghien m'a demandé de
faire ma demande est vaccinée pour me
protéger de ses futures opérations
j'ai traîné de la patte âge je voulais
pas absolument ce qu'on n'avait pas le
choix il y avait plus rien de disponible
il y avait que ce pôle études et avons
j'ai accepté parce que mon néphrologue
il a joué le héros il a hissé vaccinaux
même temps que moi voilà d'accord pour
vous convaincre
on ne combat qu donc je me suis vacciné
et après on a entendu tout ce qu'on a
entendu mais celui le médecin va
accepter de recevoir la deuxième
injection
alors lui je sais pas de piste les
paroles d'accord parce que vous vous
refusez suite à la polémique qui sévit
mois depuis depuis la semaine dernière
avec tout ce qu'on l'a entendu c'est pas
c'est pas possible
mais quand l' agence européenne des
médicaments dit que c'est sûr efficace
et qui a pas plus de danger qu'avec
d'autres produits un qui me le prends
alors il faudrait quoi pour vous
convaincre
moi vous savez aujourd'hui on me dit
monsieur vous prenez de la commune à la
cohmad in donc ne l'avait pas de risque
soit j'ai pas de risque mais qui peut me
parler de ceux de cette molécule dans
six mois un an
qu'est-ce qu'on peut que ce qu'est ce
qui peut nous arriver
pour vous convaincre faudrait 70 ans de
recul oui
docteur je retourne la question qu'est
ce que vous pouvez dire pour convaincre
patrick de recevoir la deuxième
injection
d'abord juste une question pour un
profane comme moi qu'est ce qui se passe
si on reçoit qu'une seule injection de
l'astra zeneca alors c'était efficace à
très court terme
je ne sais pas efficace très d'accord
donc il faut la deuxième injection
absolument mais chacun est le problème
de la vaccination c'est que chacun est
libre de gérer ça son pic comme il peut
mais il ya quand même un effet collectif
alors qu'elle est quels sont les
arguments que vous pourriez exposé à
patrick pour le convaincre
il a l'air très décidé à pas la recevoir
bah j'essaierai de voir avec lui
pourquoi il a un tel refus face à une
information qui paraît objectivement
bonne c'est un vrai souvent appelée
j'avais quand même avant avancer ce
passage de tout ce qu'on a entendu la
semaine dernière il ya eu comme un en
avant moi j'ai eu du mal si tu en prends
mon efron a été obligé de me convaincre
pour que je puisse me vacciner avec
cette je comprends et il ya un effort de
communication qui n'a pas été fait
contrairement à notre pays qui n'a pas
été fait pour expliquer pourquoi il y
avait un vaccin qui avait un profil et
un vaccin cave un autre profil
le problème de l'astra zenica c'est que
les études ont été faits sur les moins
de 65 ans et donc qu'on avait aucune
visibilité sur les plus de 65
ça a été une des vraies difficultés
depuis on les a maintenant mais il faut
voir comment sont construits les
dossiers des des médicaments c'est c'est
compliqué de commercialiser sur tous de
plusieurs centaines de millions de doses
on n'est pas tout je peux mais personne
ne sait si ça vient ça va tellement dure
je veux dire c'est rationnellement quand
on regarde ce vaccin et l'efficacité qui
l'a par rapport à votre situation par
rapport à une éventuelle intervention
qui pourrait vous être proposé dans le
cadre d'une greffe
bah c'est si vous êtes protégé c'est
vachement mieux pour toi qu'on lui ait
fait que nous sommes de légers de boxe
n'est pas tant d un point très important
qu'est ce qui va se passer alors moi ce
que je souhaite c est ce que je peux
faire
c'était une question que je voulais vous
poser est ce que je peux choisir ma
prochaine molécules où je suis obligé de
refaire la phrase alors yahia
médicalement il est préférable de
refaire la phrase et nika parce que
c'est comme ça que c'est
les protocoles sont construits rien
n'empêche techniquement de vous re
vaccinés avec un autre produit dans ce
cas c'est ce que vous êtes vous qu'elle
a demandé la parole juste pour être
complet il faut dire aussi que dès qu'il
est question d'astrazeneca ce sont des
mauvaises nouvelles
bah oui ils ont livré seulement un quart
des doses qu'ils avaient promis à
l'union européenne
il s'était planté dans les tests sur les
personnes âgées notamment et là il ya
une nouvelle polémique banques
ceci précisé je passerai par la famille
qui est à fond d'amérique
oui on est vraiment typiquement dans un
cas ou peut-être que si on avait le
choix si on avait davantage de vaccins
dans le portefeuille français peut-être
qu'on pourrait résoudre dans un certain
nombre de réticences je l' ai déjà dit
ici mais moi mes parents par exemple au
chili ont été vaccinés avec le vaccin
chinois et nous on s'est mis dans une
seringue et le cadre de dire qui est la
seringue de la gestion par l'union
européenne et qui nous empêche d'avoir
un portefeuille plus large en voilà on
n'a pas le vaccin russe n'a pas le
vaccin chinois en a pas on n'aura
peut-être pas le vaccin cubain 1 et
ainsi de suite
et c'est d'autant plus dommageable que
sur l'astra zeneca j'ai moi j'ai regardé
la conférence de presse aujourd'hui seul
agence européenne du médicament
j'ai pas tout à fait la même lecture que
vous parce que sur efficace alors que
dit l'agent --l'agence ne dit pas
seulement ça et quand même il faut il
faut quand même faire une information
complète à nos téléspectateurs ce que
dit lagence c'est qu'effectivement un
trouve que c'est sûr mais elle dit aussi
que elle n'a pas pu démontrer que les
thromboses les caillots n'était pas due
aux vaccins c'est la raison pour
laquelle elle recommande désormais que
l'administration de 7 de ce vaccin
viennent avec une notice d'avertissement
oui pour les d'accord tous les
médicaments la loi okei okei sauf que
maintenant c'est une requête nouvelle
qui est de m et pour qu effectivement en
tant que patient guillemets en soit
chacun en mesure de me merkel
je n'arrive pas précisé que ces cas ne
sait d'ailleurs si mauvais d'accord here
is kill et prendre sa décision librement
l'a bien cherché
l'agent se dit aussi que ça n'augmente
pas les risques mais que la trop beau
existe il peut y avoir une corrélation
si vous avez évidemment des pathologies
écouter à de la directrice et elle l'a
dit noir sur blanc elle a dit nous
n'avons pas pu démontrer que les
cailloux ne venait pas du vaccin raison
pour laquelle dont il a fait sa
différence